i'm going to talk today about
how to do massively parallel processing
with something that's called procedural
python
and we'll get on to why that is why it's
called procedural python later on
but the idea is that i'm going to just
show you a few little things
a little demo with my python notebook
and
hopefully all run because it's actually
live talking to a database somewhere in
america
so and as was said i'm a data scientist
at pivotal
and pivotal is a relatively new company
it was formed last year out of parts of
emc and vmware just quickly if you
haven't got these links
and there's the ipython notebooks in
that github repository and then there's
a rendered version down there i'll put
these slides up on
the web later on so what is pivotal well
pivotal was formed out of lots of
different parts of two companies as i
said emc and vmware
and the idea is to try and bring
together some of the sort of big data
components of those two companies so
there might be a lot of things you've
actually heard of before but never
really connected with pivotal
and so things like pivotal labs our
agile software development team
and things like cloud foundry our
platform for cloud independent
apps and if you're a java programmer
you've
hopefully heard of the spring framework
uh millions of java programmers use it
every day
and then we've got things like our data
layer so our data fabric as we call it
which includes the greenclub analytics
database a hadoop distribution like
everyone else
and also things like our in-memory uh
database system called gemfire and sql
fire
so just briefly to tell you where i'm
coming from
with what i'm talking about later on the
customers that we have
are normally large enterprises with lots
of data but maybe aren't using it to the
best of their abilities so they have
you know terabytes to petabytes and of
data
structured and unstructured and they're
trying to they want to do something more
with it they
maybe they want to you know reduce the
fraud that they're seeing
and in their banking transactions maybe
they want to understand their customer
better
maybe they maybe they want us you know
sell more clothes or understand how
fashion
is changing week to week and month to
month
what they're not able to do at the
moment is get what they want out of the
data because they're you know
unlike maybe say a smaller more agile
company they're lumbered with you know
large and
relatively old legacy technologies and
that have high cost and pretty limited
flexibility
one of the main things we see when we go
into a company is that the response
times
for doing you know some data science or
interactive
uh data analysis the response times are
really low so
are really long i suppose so you send
out a query and it comes back you know
in six hours or the next day or
something like that
whereas really what we want to help
enable our customers do is
to get down to interactive data science
so you know i'm putting in a query and
i'm getting something out
so that i can try the next query so i
can you know fail quickly
and get onto the next query fast
just quickly a few other things you
might have heard of that pivotal
is part of or contributes to or provides
support to are things like
redis rabbit mq grails and groovy
and and in fact we now have one of the
the main hadoop committers
uh as part of our team they're in the
middle with this mad lib library that
i'm going to talk a little bit more
about
and if you want to know how to interface
with madlib through python
there's this wrapper called pymadlib
that one of my colleagues wrote
and that enables you to do that madlib
is an
open source machine learning library for
use
on large scale massively parallel
databases
in fact it works with postgres it works
with greenplum
and now also works on some hadoop
frameworks like impala and hawk as well
so when we go into a customer engagement
what sort of technology do we have on
our side well normally
um because i work for pivotal we have
something like the green plum database
or our hadoop distribution
with hawke which is a sequel on hadoop
solution there are open source options
for all of these things so there's a
green plum community edition
and a pivotal hd community edition as i
said madlib is
completely open source but where does
python fit into all of this well
we use python in the same way that a lot
of you do maybe for exploratory analysis
in ipython using you know numpy and
scipy and
pandas and matplotlib but we also use
this other thing
which is pl python so this is a way of
leveraging python inside a database
and so you already have your massively
parallel database you know
large costs a lot of money it's very
large it does lots of computation very
fast
we want to be able to enable you to use
python not just
you know some sql or sql-like language
in there
and the benefit of using pl python is
that we get to use all the great
packages like nltk or scikit-learn and
all those things
inside the database we don't have to
bring the data
back locally to our laptop to enable
those analyses
and that's one of the big themes for us
is bringing code
to the to the data not bringing the data
to the code
you know obviously that gets more
important the larger the data sets
you're looking at
okay let's let's switch then to the
ipad's notebook and see if that works
okay so we've probably skipped a little
bit of the intro but basically the idea
is that
you have a postgres database and now
you think about how can i make this work
better with larger amounts of data well
if i had
20 machines or 100 machines i could put
postgres databases on all of them
and then have a master node that
actually connects to all of those
and tells each of those what to do so
when you submit a query you submit it to
the master node
that parses the query figures out where
the data lives on that distributed
computing system
and then sends the queries down to those
distributed systems
gathers it up together and gives you the
answer so
you know the simple way to think about
something like the green plum database
is to think of postgres living
on a cluster and being controlled by
some master node
okay and where pl python comes in
is that pl python is um
basically allows you to write functions
for your database
that aren't in sql so in sql databases
you normally have things called
user-defined functions udfs it's a way
of writing
and a sql you know some query in sql
that you then wrap in a function and can
call repeatedly
pl python is a way of writing a python
function
inside that sql wrapper okay in fact you
can do this with
other languages as well there's plr and
i think there's even pl
java and there's another thing called
plpg sql
which is postgres's sort of iterative
programming language
that looks like sql but not quite you
can assign variables and those sort of
things
so obviously we won't get the
interactive bit here but you can see
what's going to happen
and so first of all this whole thing is
a bit uh
it's a bit confusing because what i'm
going to be doing now is i'm going to be
using an ipython notebook
to call some sql database using sql pure
sql
that pure sql in the middle of it
somewhere will have a little bit of
python so there's actually layers of
python sql to python again and the way
we're able to do this is with this
really handy um
little magic command called ipython sql
by uh catherine devlin and there's a
it's on github so you can go get it but
what you need to do first of all is just
load
load the magic command and then i'm just
going to connect to my database
and if you work in large databases you
normally create a schema it's just like
a sandbox to
keep all your it's like a namespace
really to keep all your names placed
together
okay so first of all let's look at what
uh
we can put this bigger what
a a normal user defined function looks
like okay
so obviously the syntax highlighting
doesn't quite work here but
the idea is that you have some simple
sql commands
like create function you give it the
name and you give it the type of
argument to put in here an integer and
tell it what it's going to return again
an int
and then in between these dollar signs
these two dollar signs
this is the actual body of the function
so here it's super simple it's select
two times
my first argument okay
so as you might imagine when you run
that
you get you just do because we're in sql
you have to use the select
you get select the function and some
argument
and the answer you get out is 20 so it
works
to go on to pl python is really simple
basically in between the dollar signs
now
instead of writing sql you want to write
actual python
so here we have just you know really
simple if a greater than b
return a otherwise return b the outside
looks quite similar you've got
create function you have to give it
types you have to tell it it's going to
return
an integer and then at the bottom here
you
specify which language you're doing this
in
and this is called the language is
called pl python u the u stands for
untrusted so
in fact to be to install this on your
database you have to have
admin privileges that's because you know
with python you can do anything you can
in fact
access the base file system of the
computer that your database is sitting
on and running that query on
so you know if you're an administrator
that probably signs a few alarm bells
and but that's just the way it is
unfortunately i think there's
there are efforts to try and make a
trusted version but that would obviously
limit the
capabilities of the python interpreter
inside it
so we've created this function plp
pimax give it two integers and it
returns the larger one
and here we're going to test it and
again it's just simple select
from this function give it two
interviews
and then you get the result out and if
you've ever worked with
you know sql style databases before
maybe you can start
thinking about how you can make this
more complex this select
the function can live in a select
statement so you can start doing things
like
um select function and then a column
name
and you get whatever is coming into that
column from your
table you can add it in and you can put
this inside
another function like a
sorry udf
and you can also do things like
returning composite types that your
database will understand as rows
so here we want to return you know
i suppose in some way a tuple of a name
and a value
again you have to type them so you give
them a text type
and an integer type here
but that means now that when we go and
look at our
creating a function down here we can
actually return
here i've returned a list with the name
and value inside python
you know the types don't matter
so they can return just a list with name
and value and then
when i do that then here sorry okay
let's just go down and look when i do
that
say make pair with a name here's zozimus
and
value say one the output that i get is
that pair
coming back to me
inside the python parts you don't need
to worry too much about what sort of
container it's in so it can be
a tuple it can be a list it can also be
a dictionary with the
the uh names of the return values as the
uh sorry the names here name and value
and in the dictionary it can in fact be
an object
that has attributes dot name and dot
value as well so you know you can
imagine doing
doing something in psychic learning
getting some object back or getting some
results set back
and you know yes you have to do some
extra leg work to create this type up
here
but once you've done that your database
actually understands the parts of that
python object that you're returning and
is able to put them in the right place
and knows the right types for them
okay so we tried out this function and
we got this pair back
which you know in the database looks
like
um you're getting a result result set
i suppose
the next thing i want to talk about is
how you can actually
um well first of all you can note that
udfs
and pl python functions and are allowed
to have
multiple function signatures so
previously my function had a name and a
value
and down here now we're just just using
a name
and so sometimes people use this sort of
maybe uh well i don't know they
use it to overload the function to do
things like provide help
you know sql isn't a nice uh programming
language like python where you can just
introspect things
and or you can you know find uh
comments inside the function or doc
comments or whatever
so people do silly like interesting
things like having a
function with no arguments gives you
back the help or a function with the
word help in it
gives you back the help documentation
okay but apart from that we can also
as i said leverage the power of
python packages inside these pl python
calls now to do this you have to have
installed
the package and all its dependencies on
each of the nodes of your database
so you know i'd recommend doing that
with some kind of package maintainer
maybe conda something like that
and and the way we do it in greenplum is
that we have this
uh parallel ssh kind of system where i
log in
one login and i'm actually logged into
the whatever 10 20
30 computers all at the same time so
that you know lets you
install these things quite quickly once
i've done that once i have numpy
say on my database and all this on all
the nodes and all the segments of the
database
i can use it inside these pl python
functions so again this is really simple
and but say just you know
inside here numpy just make this array
and then just return the name that we
were given and some value from that
array
and here again i'm returning this named
value type up here
okay so when we do that now we get back
um the name and one of those elements of
that array
so one thing to know about to note about
uh sql database is the calling semantics
for
these functions whether they're uh where
they are in the select statement
are they part of the from clause um or
are they at the beginning
actually affects how the results come
back to you so before we had select
make pair horatio or whatever and we got
the back the results as a
i suppose as a tuple in some ways if we
in fact do select star now
we will actually get back the columns
and and you can reference those then in
a
you know in a further outside query or
you can put them straight into a table
and or you could do all those sort of
things so you know the database has now
understood that there's two values
name and value here and we can do
whatever we want with them
after that
so i've only so far returned
one result so you know one line of uh
center query out
i've got one line back of a result can i
get more than that you know if i do a
complicated
um complicated query complicated
uh numerical calculation i'll probably
get a lot of results that i want to get
back and store in my database
how do i do that well that the easiest
way to do that is return
a set of something so that just tells
the the database that in fact there's
going to be more than one query
so be ready to get like however many
rows are going to come out of this query
by the end
so here again if i import numpy i can
return
here three different queries or three
different results
and the way they come back is just at if
i do
again select star the way they come back
is at three different rows
of the result set for my query okay so
you know
we're actually playing within the rules
of the database semantics
and this allows you as i said to put
these things together
and put it in a sub-query save the
results into a table
and all those things that you would do
with standard sql results anyway you can
do
with these uh with these
python functions
okay but you know that's great and all
we can use it to to run some python but
why why do we want to do this well
really the reason we want to do this
is to leverage the parallelization
possible when you have this large
distributed system
so you know pivotal we we have this data
computing appliance where we have
um what was it 16
blades each with four cores so once you
start leveraging that you can actually
get
quite large speedups in how you do
queries one of the main things you need
to
think about though is that your data is
going to live
on this database but in different places
how you distribute that data is actually
very important so whether you distribute
it
by one column or another can make a
large difference
because if you end up doing a query
which and
for example joins say we have
users sorry say we have customers orders
and customer information we have
customer information in one table
we've order information in another table
and we want to
join those two tables together if we
keep all the customers
and you know alpha alphabetized across
my
system but in fact the orders are done
by order number
then each time i want to join those two
tables together we're going to have to
go
find which order refers to which
customer maybe go to a different machine
with all the network traffic that that
entails
to find the customer name and then get
their information
whereas if i distribute my data across
the system
based on for example a customer id value
so all the customers with id values one
to ten are on compute are on
node one ten to twenty are on node 2
like that
if i then distribute the orders in the
same way so an order that went to
customer id 1 lives on the first
box then doing those joins becomes much
quicker
the data lives in the same place there's
no network traffic and everything is
good
so one of the main things when we go to
customers and we talk about their data
is how have they distributed it can't do
we need to change that
do we understand the kind of queries
we're going to be making so that we can
make an informed decision about where
the data should live
in order to enable this sort of speed up
with the parallelization as
quickly as possible obviously there's
you know still some speed up if the data
has to move and you
but you have multiple processing units
but in order to keep the data in the
same place
and it makes sense sorry in order to
speed up the calculation as much as
possible
it makes sense to keep the data in the
same place and when you're talking about
petabytes and
joining two petabyte size tables that
makes a big difference
so let's see what this looks like in
terms of
the pl python so this was just this is
just generating some data basically
i have three uh series here one a b and
c
the first one is just uh floating point
values from
zero to i suppose what like ten thousand
the next one is taking the sign of that
and then
c is just the sign except boosted by a
hundred
okay
and in fact you can see here what i've
done is i've said i want to distribute
this data by the column called name
so up here a is is the column name
and when i tell the database to
distribute it by name
what i'm saying is that look in the
column name
see all the values that are there do
something
probably a hash of those values and then
put that data
in the right place so that the hashes
that are the same
live on the same box so you know
you have to be very careful the way you
do this you don't want to and you've got
a petabyte size database
60 different nodes you can store it on
if the
column you distribute by is a gender
male female
column then in fact you only have two
places that you want to store it
so you've put all your you know two
petabytes onto
two of the boxes and left the other 58
or whatever 62 empty so you have to be
careful that the cardinality of the set
that you're using to do the distribution
is large enough that it makes full use
of the number of nodes that are
available to you
so here in this case maybe we've we've
only got three
so it's not quite true but you know in a
bigger example you'd have to do that
okay so i've three i've lots of data now
three million lines of something
and if i just go and
naively create a function say i want to
just find the mean of all those numbers
you know i know i could do that in sql
but let's do it in numpy for fun
what i have to do is give that
pl python function the argument has to
be an array
of all the numbers that i want to use so
here what i've said is there's some
array value array
and it's a double precision array
okay so an array of floating point
numbers it only returns one float but
you give it
an array of lots of floats inside this
is straightforward we
you know we just return the the mean of
the array
but how i call this now i've slightly
have to change my semantics
and so if the column y is the the number
we're trying to get the mean of
i want to take it out of this test data
table
but i don't want to give it to the
function if i called it as
as we were before say np mean brackets y
then what i get is the mean of one
number i give the
the function one number i get the mean
of that number back and then do that for
every single number in that table
instead what we want to do is give it
all the data at once so use this
function in postgres called arrayag
which basically takes a column
of like a result column of results puts
them into an array
and uses that as one object and hands
that to the function
okay so i've got a mean here i just
sorry i've got this function i'm going
to give it an array
of all the values in the y column for my
data
and then we're going to see what we get
back and in fact we get back
the mean of all those numbers together
but really what we want to do is we want
to do separate models for
each of those data each of those types
of data we have here it's obviously a
contrived example but maybe you want to
do
you know maybe we have customers in lots
of different european countries there
are
lots of different states in the us and
we want to do a um
a customer clustering model for each of
those countries
we don't want to do an overall model um
or i think jurgen was talking earlier in
the
in the hierarchical classification about
doing a model for for each product
category
to do that now we just use the sql
semantics of group by
which means we just put the name at the
front of the
statement here and
then down here we say we want to group
by the name so for each
value in name pull all those results
together
the order by just means we'll get the
results in the in sort of alphabetical
order here
and then we do the function and here y
now isn't the results for the whole
table it's the y values for each group
labeled by name so we had a b and c
so now we're going to what we're going
to do is we're going to give all the y
values that correspond to
name a give that to the function get
something back
then do it for b then do it for c and in
this way you've naively paralyzed your
problem
very quickly because all the data as i
said before we distributed it
lives on different boxes those boxes can
go ahead and do the
the calculation and give us back the
results and what you get back is
something like this and in fact you know
this shows us what we were our contrived
example earlier one of them has mean
5000 that's the one that just
goes up in step this is the the sign
around zero again so the mean should be
around zero yeah that's okay
and this one is uh the one that is
boosted by a hundred so again
the results are okay so you can imagine
how to how to uh do this for more
complex examples
and maybe we want to do you know machine
learning models or we want to use
scikit-learn and we want to do something
like that and we want to do it in all
these different categories
all at the same time so let's do
something more complicated
here i'm just going to do a linear
regression okay not very much more
complicated i'm going to do a linear
regression
on those uh arrays of numbers so
you know we're now giving it two
arguments the x and the y array you're
going to return a float of arrays
sorry an array of floats and we're just
going to use scipy
stats module and you know simple lin
regress
and see what happens so again if i do it
for all the data
i get back a linear regression model
that you know
worked across all the data and gave me
back here we have the
the slope and the intercept and the some
of the errors
but i know that i want to do this model
not as i said not for
all my customers across europe but i
want to have an individual model for
each country
or i want to have an individual model
for each product line or i want to have
an individual model for each
type of bank transaction something like
that
can i leverage the power of the
parallelization to do all those models
in parallel and yes i can so
as we had before simply use the group by
semantics
so you have name function and then group
by down here
and i will go off run your python scipy
linear regression on each of those
arrays
and what you get back as the results
are the three results for the linear
regression in the first case
yeah well we actually yeah it is pretty
much a straight line with this slope
going up
in the second case it's picked out and
you know
the horizontal sl horizontal line that
goes through the mean of all the the
sine functions
and here we can see that it's actually
picked out for the third case
uh the y-intercept is 100 as we had put
in our data
okay so that was really the end of my
little demo hopefully we've used up
enough time that i don't need to try and
get my slides working for the rest
and if you want to see what i was
supposed to
talk about from my powerpoint and come
up and talk to me afterwards or
connect with me on twitter it's just at
ian houston h-u-s-t-o-n
i'm going to take a few questions now
then so thank you yeah
so the question is how does this affect
the execution plan that the query
analyzer in the database comes up with
yeah exactly so if you have you know a
large database you have an execution or
a query planner
that looks at the query you're trying to
do and tries to figure out the best way
to do it
it does not know about python and it
knows that there's some function it has
to call
it doesn't know how long it's going to
take and it you know if you think about
it it can't really unless it understood
and you know all the insides and outs of
python and
all the packages and numpy et cetera so
no it does the query plan doesn't
understand the query analyzer doesn't
understand the uh
the cost associated with doing these
things you know i think basically you're
given the power
you know you've got a full python
interpreter inside uh each node of your
database now you could do anything you
could start
writing files to disk you could do all
that sort of stuff it's giving you a lot
of power
and with that comes a lot of
responsibility
so would it like once you've done it
once or twice would it try and collect
i'm not sure i can check i don't think
so i think it kind of thinks of it as a
black box
and you know you can imagine
there being difficulties because uh it's
not
concrete what how what the run time is
going to be each time you call this
function like
sometimes it might be very quick
sometimes it might be very slow
depending
excuse me depending on the inputs
depending on what's actually happening
inside
so i have a feeling it just it just kind
of takes a step back and says
uh you know you're responsible for
running this query and knowing how long
it's going to take
yeah it was a good question
yeah you talked about moving the
execution
to the data rather than execution i'm
wondering what sort of
um and scalability you get
are you not restricted and we're going
to require something for a query
system so
i suppose yes you are you're going to
have to have some way of
handling those and you know there is a
and
a queuing system uh for clients
connecting to the database basically
everything is handled by the master
nodes the master node
you know dictates to everyone who's
trying to connect
what's going to run and you can have a
proper scheduling system with higher
priority queries versus lower priority
queries
so obviously you know you want some
queries to be run immediately some
queries or
maybe you want to slow down the way you
know maybe taking a
broader view the way we think about
doing analytics is that you should try
and have an analytics environment
that enables you to do interactive
queries and it probably shouldn't be
your
production batch environment that is
doing you know the payroll at the end of
the week or whatever it is
you don't want your data scientists to
think you can't run a query because
he's worried that he's going to stop you
know the pay slips being delivered the
next day
and so yeah it's an important thing to
figure out i think
um sort of cost benefits you get
from and being able to bring the code to
data
mean you know speed up just the
process for data analysis and data
science so much that actually
uh you know instead of trying to bring
all the things to your your laptop
which obviously will crash at some point
and
i think the speed up we get is worth the
sometimes you know sometimes there's a
bit of chat on the email list about you
know who's running that query why did
you let it keep going
please can you cancel this like you know
it's it's run a muck can you
can you shut it down that sort of thing
yeah yeah i'm just startup cost so
depending on your machine you know if
you're setting your laptop and you type
it in pylab
you might be counting to i don't know
three four five before it starts up
now obviously the goal of your you know
analytic platform as you say for sort of
sandboxing is
is true interactivity and you you type
query and it comes straight back
um is there a way to sort of get a
python interpreter to be sitting there
with all that stuff already loaded and
then when it gets the code it just goes
i already know numpy i already know you
know
psychic learn whatever whatever the the
the libraries are
because that seems like that should be
possible right it should be possible to
have it sitting there and ready to go
with with the
stuff loaded if you tell it ahead of
time but i don't know how you did
yeah so the question was can i have a
python environment that's ready to go
and load it up with all the libraries
whatever
and i suppose inside the database on
each of the segments and
yes that brings up a good point each
time you run this function you're
actually creating
an interpreter that has to load
everything and you know if there are
loading costs associated then
they factor in interpreter itself yeah
yeah
exactly so i think you know
this way of doing it that's not the way
it's set up and
you know each time it runs one of these
procedural functions whether it's python
or r or java or whatever
it spins out a process to run the
associated interpreter
it doesn't have a long-running
interpreter in the back end
you know obviously you know there's a
different paradigm
way of thinking about it you could just
have a compute cluster and
you know using something like ipython
clusters where you have all the
the iphone kernels sitting out on your
cluster
waiting waiting for you to send it but
then again you're sending then you're
sending data to it unless you've
you know managed to to make the data
live in the right place
yeah in so
uh one of the problems with running
distributed systems is debugging them
remotely
um what is the debug support line for
retrieving
tracebacks or interacting impossible or
broken query this is a very good
question
it's probably not as good as you'd have
you know just running something locally
i think you do get uh uh stack trace
multi-multi-processing
yeah exactly so if something goes wrong
i think you
you do get a stack trace back now you
if something goes wrong on all the nodes
you'll get you know 64 stack traces back
and so being able to to work through
that
sql is not known for its uh you know
ins what's the word i'm looking for
informative error
error uh logs so you know sometimes you
might just get back
something is wrong here somewhere and it
takes you know
really it's wrong at the first place
that it actually you know caught the
uh syntax error or whatever yeah it's
you know i don't think we have a great
way of doing it yet it's something we
kind of need to work on
so you yeah have a background worker
here is
running and then you get asynchronous
events
somewhere else so i haven't used them
recently i think there is a way
definitely in greenplum database there's
a way of defining triggers
and yeah maybe come talk to me
afterwards and i can
i can look it up and it's not something
i've used
recently